- Hey everyone.
This is Jeremy Schifeling
with Khan Academy.
Thank you so much for joining us today.
I'm super excited for a really
action packed session today,
and I think this is a very
timely session as well
as we head into the last month
of an incredibly tough year.
I think one of the things
that 2020 has taught us is,
even in this moment of social isolation,
how much we need each other,
how much we need partners and
collaborators in our lives.
And that's why I'm so
grateful in this moment
of gratitude for our
partners at Headspace,
because as much as we at Khan Academy love
to focus on academics and
Scholastic development.
We also know this year is about that more
holistic idea of serving your students.
How do you make sure that their social
and emotional needs are met,
as well as your own as educators?
And so that's why I'm
thrilled to introduce you
to two rockstar presenters from Headspace.
First, we have Sam Snowden,
who is a mindfulness
facilitator who specializes
in supporting students and teachers,
so has worked with tons of folks
exactly like yourselves
for years at this point,
and has actually worked directly
with elementary schools,
with principals, with
educators across the world.
And she's joined by Alice Nathoo,
who's the head of social
impact at Headspace.
And what she does there
is a larger portfolio
that also includes
Headspace for Educators,
which is an amazing program if you
haven't checked it out already,
which basically gets you all
the power of Headspace for free,
just for doing the great work
that you do as an educator.
And Alice will share more
about that in a little bit.
In the meantime, before we dive in,
I want to answer sort
of three housekeeping
questions that typically come up.
Number one, in true webinar fashion,
yes, the session will be recorded,
and you will get a copy
of it automatically
in your inbox right after the session.
Number two, as educators ourselves,
we want to make this super interactive.
So ask questions at any
point using the questions tab
on your go to webinar control panel,
and also join lots of our pop quizzes
that Sam will be sending
your way throughout.
And then third and finally,
I know a lot of you were interested
in the Headspace swag bag,
so free access to the Headspace platform
for friends and family,
as well as a copy of their
best-selling book on mindfulness.
Just for being here live with us today,
you're automatically
entered into a drawing
for one of those five swag bags,
and we will notify you after the session
if you're one of those lucky winners.
So that being said,
thank you all again for making time
and investing in today's session with us.
And with that being said,
I want to turn it over to Sam and Alice
- Well, what an introduction.
Thank you so much, Jeremy.
And thank you Khan Academy, you know,
for this opportunity to talk to you all.
Hello, welcome,
congratulations for making
this time for yourself.
As Jeremy said, I'm Alice Nathoo,
and I run Headspace for Educators.
As a parent, you know,
this has been such a hard year,
and I can only imagine
for you all as educators,
renewed respect for the jobs that you do.
The incredible job you do,
and how challenging it's been
this year for you, I'm sure.
So I'm really excited to introduce Sam.
I have to say my meetings with Sam
are my favorite part of the day.
There's just something about her
that just is instantly relaxing.
So I'm so excited we get to spend
this half an hour together.
But first, we thought we'd just,
before I sort of introduce Sam,
just to give you a little idea
of what we're going to cover today.
As Jeremy said, we want
this to be really practical.
I mean, what we say at Headspace
is meditation made simple,
and that's what we
thought about for today.
What are some simple exercises for you
to use for yourself and for your students?
So Sam's going to talk a bit
about what mindfulness is.
Don't worry if you've got,
if you have a lot of experience,
or you have no experience at all,
hopefully there'll be
something for everyone here.
And really then how it can help you
optimize your learning environment,
both remotely and hopefully
back in the classroom too.
And then we'll finish
off with some Q and A.
So I'm so excited to introduce Samantha.
Jeremy did a wonderful introduction.
You know, we're really excited to work
with her on Headspace for educators.
She's an amazing human being.
So welcome my friend
and colleague Samantha.
- Thank you so much, Alice.
I feel completely overwhelmed with love,
and it's a great way to start.
And I just want to thank all of you,
all the teachers for
showing up and caring about,
you know, bettering of
your teaching practice.
And I've also been a
teacher in the classroom,
so I know the struggle.
I've been a substitute teacher,
which is kind of the hardest gig, I think.
So all of the things
that I'll be offering you
definitely come from a place
of embodied experience.
I've tried them out,
they're tried and true methods
for bringing mindfulness
into your own life and also
into your students' lives.
So I'm just so grateful to be here.
And I'm so grateful to all of you
for all the hard work you're doing.
So I wanted us to start out
actually with a practice.
We'll be doing a couple
practices together,
and the reason for that is that,
when you embody the practice,
when you do it yourself,
you have a better idea of how
to lead it with your students.
And so I want to just preface that with
if you want to keep your
eyes open the whole time,
I'm going to invite you
to keep your eyes closed,
but if you want to keep them open
you can just rest your attention
on a spot in front of you,
a few inches or a few
feet in front of you,
and just let your eyelids
kind of rest halfway closed.
And the first practice we're going
to be doing is working with anchors.
And when I talk about
anchors with my students
I often show them this little bell.
And I talk about how anchors keep a boat,
right, from drifting too far away.
So if this is our anchor and our
boat wants to follow the waves,
or if this is like our
mind and our mind wants
to follow different streams of thought,
the anchor brings it back.
And it brings it back again,
and again, and again.
And over time we get much
better at paying attention.
We get more control over our attention
so that it doesn't feel like
it is being taken away from us,
but we have some mastery over it.
So this is really a foundational practice
that you can do with your students.
We're going to do a three minute,
around a three-minute practice,
but you can even shorten it to a one
minute practice with your students.
So if you're ready, I don't know you,
maybe you're driving in a car,
or if it's not safe to do a practice,
please, you know,
just listen and participate that way.
But if you are in a semi-private space
and you feel comfortable,
you can join along with me.
So the first thing we start
with is our body posture.
So you want to have your
feet flat on the floor,
and you just want to bring
some length to your spine.
I like to tell the kids
to imagine that someone
has a string right at
the top of their head,
and they're just gently
pulling that string
and it's lengthening the spine.
And then when you're ready,
you can close your eyes.
And I like to start with just
a little bit of squeezing and releasing.
We call this progressive
muscle relaxation,
just to help you get into your body.
So let's just start with our shoulders.
Just bringing your shoulders
up toward your ears,
and giving a little squeeze.
And hold this for just a few seconds.
And then take a nice deep
breath in through your nose.
And as you exhale, just let
the shoulders relax down,
away from your ears.
And so we've all arrived, hopefully,
in this still posture.
And as we're sitting still for
maybe the first time today,
we might notice our mind is so busy.
So we're going to bring
just a natural curiosity
to notice what our body
feels like in this moment.
Are our eyelids fluttering,
is our heartbeat racing
or is it really slow?
Do we feel sleepy?
So just notice.
And then you're just going to start
to take a couple of deep breaths,
feeling your belly go out
and in as you breathe.
So let's breathe in through our nose,
and out through our nose.
You can think of the words breathing in,
breathing out.
And then imagine it as a whisper,
breathing in, breathing out.
And now just hear it as
a whisper in your mind.
See if you can let go of any
control over your breathing,
so that your breath is just natural.
You don't have to remember
to breathe or try to breathe.
Breathing will just happen on it's own.
And we're just breathing our breath,
staying with the feeling or the sensation
of the belly going out and in.
And if your mind starts to drift away,
just like the boat
drifting away on the waves,
just label your thinking
as thinking, or planning,
or maybe noticing sounds.
And then very gently,
very kindly come back to
the words breathing in,
breathing out,
and the sensations in
your belly as you breathe.
And before we end our practice,
see if there's one thing
that you noticed today
about your breath that
you never noticed before.
When you're ready, you
can slowly open your eyes,
coming back to our space together.
And I'm just curious,
maybe in the chat you can mention
one thing that you noticed.
You might've noticed.
I notice usually if I'm amped
up and I have a lot of energy,
that my eyelids are fluttering
or that my heart is beating.
So it's very sematic.
It's very body driven if I'm amped up.
But if I'm sleepy I might
notice heaviness in my eyes.
I might notice, you know,
dreams of falling asleep or, you know,
cravings to get in my bed and sleep.
So it's different.
What we're noticing is different each,
depending on how we're feeling.
So if you'd like to share something
that you've noticed from this practice,
you can go ahead and share in the chat.
And I believe I can see--
- [Jeremy] A lot of folks are really
sort of getting into this.
Deanna mentioned the tension in her neck.
Kim says, I noticed my
head hurt a little bit.
Emily noticed, here we are in December,
and I have a stuffy nose.
So definitely a lot of sense of heaviness
and weariness at this point of the year.
- Thank you guys for sharing that too.
And so anything you're noticing,
whether it's pleasant,
unpleasant, or neutral,
is practicing mindfulness.
That's the muscle that
we're trying to flex
with ourselves and with our students.
So that's really good noticing,
and they're things that,
if you think about the
categories of things,
we can pay attention to.
The one that we all mentioned
in this practice was sensation, right?
That's a huge category.
Our internal body sensations.
Another category is mental activity.
So things that we're feeling,
things that we're thinking about,
or urges that we're having,
or even images that
arise in our mind, right?
Like flashes of memories from the day.
Another category is our five senses.
So we might be, when we close
our eyes like we just did,
we might notice wind.
I noticed the heater in my house.
So it's nice and toasty
and warm for my skin.
Or you might notice smells,
if you have a candle or
any scents in the house.
So that's another category,
and the final category of
things we pay attention to
has to do with our relationships.
So you might've had a memory of someone
that you love that's in your house.
That's, you know,
that you just thought, oh,
I really like that person.
Or I wonder how they're
doing, or I hope they're well.
So any, any of these,
any of the stimuli from
these different categories
can pop up during our practice,
and when we're being mindful,
we're just noticing them
with this kind of curiosity
and this openness to experience.
So this is great.
And when you're thinking about how
to bring this into your classroom,
or how to practice it with your students,
you can teach them about
anchoring just like I taught you.
And then you can set a
timer for one minute.
So once they know how
to feel their breath,
notice sensations in their body,
and think of the words
breathing in and breathing out,
they can practice in silence.
And you might start with 30 seconds
if they're really young children
and then work up and progress
to longer periods of time.
Or you can just keep it at a minute.
That's sufficient for a lot of students
in a lot of different age groups.
So that's one practice.
The second practice I want to talk to you
a little bit about is the stop practice.
And this one I've taught
to many, many children.
And I think this is their favorite,
because it's an acronym, first of all,
so they can remember the
steps and what to do.
And it's helpful because
the way we're going
to practice it now and
how you can practice it
in your classroom is to
ring a bell randomly,
or any kind of sound,
you can, you know,
program your phone to go off
at different times during the class.
And then when you hear the sound,
you're going to practice these four steps.
So the four steps,
we'll just do them kind
of briefly together.
We stop what we're doing.
And that's actually one of the
hardest things to do, right?
Is to stop ourselves from
continuing to ruminate,
or continuing to believe the thought
pattern that we're having.
So we stop, we take a deep breath,
and we can do this again
with our eyes closed.
So let's take a deep breath together.
And then we just observe.
And for this activity I'm
going to have us observe
one thing in each of our senses.
So let's start by observing a sound,
just listening to a sound we can hear.
Let's notice a smell, a scent.
Let's notice a taste in our mouths,
or just anything we notice if we run
our tongue across our teeth.
Let's notice the feeling of
our clothes against our skin.
So the insolation of our
shirts or our sweaters,
and just the feeling of being supported
by whatever surface you're on,
the weight of your body.
And finally, as we open our eyes,
just look around you and
notice something beautiful,
or something that you're grateful for.
Something that you're really glad
you have in your personal space.
Great.
So that's the stop practice.
And as far as observing,
you can prompt your students to observe
their five senses like we just did,
or you can just have them observe
whatever they're noticing in their mind.
A thought, a feeling,
a sensation.
So it's up to you depending
on what's going on
in the room or in the class.
So whenever, I'm going to read,
ring the bell twice
during our presentation.
It'll sound like this.
And I'm going to do it randomly
when you don't expect it,
and we're going to do the stop practice.
So I'll just say each word
and we'll practice together.
I just wanted to share a quick story
about the stop practice.
I had a student who was
about eight years old,
and I taught him the stop practice.
And then the next
session the parents came,
and his mom raised her hand and said,
I really want to thank you
for teaching my child this practice.
And she said that when
they had lost their dog,
their dog had run away,
the mom was getting frantic and panicky.
And she said her son said,
mom, let's stop.
Let's take a breath.
Let's observe the sensation.
And then let's proceed with more calm.
And he had led her through it,
and she said it made such a difference.
So we never know when
we're teaching our students
how this is impacting their families,
and how they're internalizing.
They often don't, aren't very emphatic,
or they're not gushing
about the experiences
they're having or learning.
But then when you hear stories like this,
it's very inspiring and
motivates you to keep going.
So I wanted to talk a little
bit about what meditation is,
and our expectations versus the reality.
So I'm not sure,
we're going to do a little poll to see
what your meditation background is.
So I don't know if many of you
have practiced before or not.
But when you first start to practice,
many people get really turned off,
get turned away by the fact
that when you close your eyes
you're bombarded with thoughts.
You're bombarded with the busyness
and the rush of your mind.
And so a lot of people will
just give up at that point,
and say, this isn't what I expected,
because there's an expectation
that we'll get calm,
that our thoughts will start
to slow down when we want them to.
But the reality is that
we're facing the busyness,
that rush, that speed of thought
that reflects the speed of our lives.
So what we're really doing,
what we're trying to cultivate
is a sense of kindness,
openness, and a willingness
to be with things as they are.
So we're sitting with whatever
shows up in our practice,
and that's why we set a timer,
because if we did this indefinitely
it would be unsustainable.
But we set a timer for, you know,
five, if we're adults,
five to 20 minutes, and
we see what shows up.
That willingness to be
with things as they are
changes the relationship we
have to our internal world.
And it becomes a lot more peaceful,
a lot more manageable
to confront our worries,
our thoughts, our projections,
and it prevents us from ruminating.
We catch ourselves in
the middle of the day,
in the middle of our lives,
when our mind starts to
ruminate or starts to overthink.
We don't want to discourage
thinking of course,
but overthinking can be problematic.
So that's a little bit
about how our expectations
really match up with with the reality
of meditation and mindfulness.
So here's a great poll.
What is your familiarity with mindfulness?
Are you new to it, have you
tried it a couple of times,
or do you have a regular practice?
And, oh,
I can't vote, sorry.
- [Jeremy] Sorry about that--
- That's okay!
- [Jeremy] The answers are coming in
fast and furious though.
More than 400 teachers across
the country have now voted,
and we'll close it in about five seconds.
- Cool.
- [Jeremy] And it looks like,
as you can see here on the screen,
a lot of folks have dabbled with it,
but also a lot of newbies as well.
- Nice.
Okay, great.
So about half have tried it a few times,
and a quarter of you
have a regular practice.
So that's, you know exactly
what I'm talking about.
And if we were together and
we could have a dialogue,
I would ask you what helps you
sustain that regular practice?
What keeps you coming back?
I know for a lot of
people, if we struggle,
I myself have struggled with anxiety,
so mindfulness was the,
it was just an amazing tool for my life.
I never thought I would teach it,
but I started practicing
at 15 and never stopped.
So it's an incredible tool.
And you all have your own
reasons for being drawn to it
or for continuing to practice it.
Awesome.
So we can go to the next slide.
- [Jeremy] Lena, if you wouldn't mind
sharing your screen once more.
Sorry about that.
We'll switch back from the poll.
There we go.
- Perfect.
- [Jeremy] Thanks everyone
for those great answers,
keep them coming.
- Let's just.
(bell ringing)
Stop, take a breath.
And this time observe the
sensation in your body.
With your hands, with your face,
and then we'll proceed.
Nice.
So, what is mindfulness?
To those of you that
have not tried it before,
or maybe only once or twice,
mindfulness is this way of being
that we actually naturally have.
It's a propensity we have,
we don't have to learn it like
we would need to learn math.
But it's often not accessible
because we're so busy,
or it's very hard to cultivate deeply,
because for the reasons I
mentioned that there's this
little learning curve we have to get over
to really rest in the practice.
So a quick definition of it is that
it's our our ability to be present
and attentive with openness,
curiosity, and a kind mind.
So building that relationship of kindness
and openness to our experiences.
And being willing, like I said before,
being willing to show up
however you are, right?
Like showing up to yourself and
witnessing what's coming up,
however it shows up.
So there's a lot of acceptance.
And when we accept what's
happening, we're not rejecting it,
because the rejection is what
causes us a lot of stress.
Trying to change,
trying to get to a certain
mindset that we want
to get to can produce kind of this inner
conflict that becomes unsustainable,
and kind of zaps us of our energy.
So why do we practice mindfulness?
I think, when I think of
teaching in the classroom,
I think of these moments I've had where
I've become a different person,
especially with students in
classrooms where there was
just no interest when I
was a substitute teacher,
and people expected to have a day off,
and I would get so agitated and so upset.
And if I didn't have
my mindfulness skills,
I think I would have turned into someone
that I didn't even recognize.
I would have probably, you know,
screamed or hit a table,
or something really, really drastic,
because there's so many moments
where there's frustration.
But if we think about using it as
a stress management tool in the classroom,
we're stopping to notice.
We're taking a moment to notice
what's going on within us.
And just the acknowledgement
of that sensation,
that thought, that emotion,
helps it to settle.
Just the pure acknowledgement of it.
We don't have to do anything more
than that most of the time.
And that allows us to stay resilient,
and to meet our students with more calm,
and to meet them with more bandwidth,
which makes the teaching
profession a sustainable one,
instead of a, you know,
one where you get burnt out in
the course of a year or two.
It also helps our physical health.
So it increases our immune system.
It strengthens our immune system.
It's correlated with longevity,
and that has to do with telomeres,
which are the little
strands at the end of,
these little frills at the end of our
DNA strands that deteriorate over time.
So studies have shown that it preserves,
it keeps those telomeres intact
for longer periods of time.
And it also helps prevent
cardiovascular disease
and inflammation in our body.
So it has tremendous health benefits,
not to mention sleep duration
and quality of sleep.
And then for our students,
it's giving them this tool to focus
and to be able to
regulate their attention,
so that when they feel their
attention drifting away,
they have a strategy.
I often ask children I work with,
who's ever told you to pay
attention, raise your hand.
And then my follow-up question is,
who's ever taught you
how to pay attention.
And there are no hands, right?
Because it's something that we,
if we're not taught we
don't really know how to do.
Some of us are naturally better at it,
and most of us I would
say are not great at it.
And it's also a tool for
emotional regulation.
So when we notice an
emotion that we're having,
and we're able to discern it, right?
We're able to finally discern
between frustration and anger,
for example, or worry and regret.
When we give kids this
vocabulary to explain,
or name, or label how they're feeling,
again, the intensity comes down,
and they stay in that zone of resilience
which allows them to bounce back
and actually resume learning,
because learning will temporarily pause
or stop if the emotion is too intense.
Thanks, we can go to the next slide.
So here's another poll for us.
In a few words,
what is one of the biggest challenges
you experienced as an educator?
And I just think of so many,
so let's see what we have here.
Burnt-out, students not showing up.
That's a big one right now.
Keeping students motivated,
grappling with technology,
and students struggling
academically or emotionally.
- [Jeremy] And this one,
educators can actually
choose as many as apply.
And we're seeing actually quite
a few choosing the burnout,
which is certainly topical tonight,
the motivation piece which also fits in
with what we're talking about.
And the struggle is probably
academically and emotionally.
So definitely all things
that we can address
with some of these mindfulness practices.
- Yes, okay.
So the biggest ones here are
the motivation component,
and then the struggle, the
academic or emotional struggle.
Absolutely.
And a lot of students right now,
I know a lot of high school
students are finding,
because friendships are so important
in their lives at that
developmental period,
that having restricted
access to their friend groups
is causing depression in a lot of them.
And also just this, like what is,
what is life even for anymore?
What is, you know,
like these existential
issues that are coming up.
So, yeah.
And I think when we're
thinking about how to address
that from a mindfulness perspective,
I think of the word compassion.
You know, just witnessing when a student's
sharing something like that with us,
just being the source of witness
and being the source of containment
for their emotional experience.
And relating to it!
Letting them know that they're not alone,
that this is part of the human experience,
and that a lot of students
are feeling this way too.
And then if we had more time,
maybe we'll have this practice
in our Headspace for
Educators group on Facebook,
but there are practices that
help you build resiliency
and help build a feeling of connection,
and joy, and ease in the midst
of these difficult emotions.
- [Jeremy] And Sam, I know
that some of the folks
from the very first exercise we did
said they had their dinner in the oven,
the ratatouille was cooking in some cases.
Do you want to finish up
with a final exercise,
or should we go into some
Q and A at this point?
What do you think is the best--
- I think we should go into some Q and A.
I want to give everyone a
chance to ask questions.
I know we're at our end time, so yeah.
Please feel free to ask any questions,
and I'm happy to address them.
And the stuff we didn't get to, again,
we have this Headspace for
Educators group on Facebook,
and we're going to be featuring
these techniques on that page.
So you can join and take part,
so that you won't miss any of this last
exercise that we didn't get
to on compassionate breathing.
- [Jeremy] Very cool.
And Alice, before we
dive into the Q and A,
and of course people should
feel free to ask questions
via the questions tab at any point,
did you want to call out anything
around Headspace for Educators
and how they access that?
- Yeah, I mean,
we've got the information here,
and as Sam said,
we'll be sharing exercises every
week in the Facebook group,
which is called Headspace for Educators.
Yeah, and I just encourage
if anyone wants to sign up,
they can just go to our
headspace.com landing page,
forward slash educators, and
all the information is there.
So yeah.
We're just excited to be able
to share these practices today,
but also welcome you to come back
and check out more through
the Facebook group.
- [Jeremy] That's awesome.
And again, like super
generous in any year,
but especially pertinent in this one.
So thank you all for sharing that
so broadly across the world.
Lots of questions are coming in.
And so I want to start with
one that Kelly had asked
at the very beginning of the session, Sam,
which is all of this is
awesome in a teacher led way,
she can really imagine
using it with her students,
but are there practices that you can help
your students with that do on their own?
So they sort of take that learning,
and make it part of their own practice
even when the teacher's not there.
- Absolutely, that's such a good question.
And I think I would say
to start with anchoring.
So to encourage them to
set a timer for one minute
after you teach them the
exercise we did in the beginning.
Using an anchor word like where it's,
like breathing in, breathing out.
Noting what they're feeling,
coming back to their anchor.
Just that simple practice is going
to help them develop
mindfulness as a trait,
as a kind of default way of relating
to their internal experiences.
So if there was one, I would point out,
I would say that one.
Another one that we'll
feature on the Facebook
group is loving kindness practice.
Or if your children are younger,
you can call them friendly wishes.
And that involves thinking about
someone that you find easy to like,
or love, a friend or loved one,
and wishing them happiness,
wishing them peace and
wishing them health.
And there's a practice
for that and recordings
so that they can practice it on their own.
We also have a lot of
material like that on the app.
So kids can access it
themselves and just press play,
and be guided through those exercises.
But I would say the anchoring
practice and friendly wishes
are two really good practices that kids,
once they learn them,
they do say that they
practice them on their own.
- [Jeremy] That's awesome, yeah.
I'm so jealous in retrospect that I didn't
learn this when I was at that age,
'cause I feel like it's such
a foundation for a great life.
You know, sort of a companion question,
very much speaking to the reality of 2020.
Carol says, if a student
wants to practice at home,
but right now home is so chaotic,
so noisy with all of the distractions
that are facing us digitally,
do you have any practical recommendations
for how students can find
that space in their home lives
to really invest in this practice?
- Absolutely, yeah.
So I mean, one way,
it might be really cold wherever you are,
so outside might not be accessible,
but if it is, you know,
going outside and just starting
the day with five senses.
I do this myself,
like I'll sit on my stairs
outside and I close my eyes.
I feel the sun on my face.
I take in a deep breath,
and I just tap into each
one of my five senses
and end with gratitude.
I just say, I ask myself,
what's one thing I'm grateful for?
So that's a very easy accessible
practice for them to do.
And I think what I'm speaking to
is the fact that it's
important to emphasize
to students that one minute is enough.
You know, even if they're,
it's a reset button,
and it's a way of setting
the tone for your day.
So they don't need to carve out
large periods of time or find,
you know, an hour of quiet
somewhere in their house.
They can just find a
little spot, you know,
maybe even in their bed.
Just sitting upright in their bed
before they get up and
start the rest of their day,
to do one minute of breathing
with a timer on their phone.
Or even lying down
before they fall asleep.
A lot of kids use the app and guided
meditation just to fall asleep,
because their minds are so
busy at the end of the day
that it's incredibly difficult.
So those are some recommendations.
I think most kids have a bed of their own,
and that's like a sacred space for them.
So encouraging them to do
practices in the morning
or before they fall asleep can
be really helpful for them.
- [Jeremy] I love that.
And I think that'll resonate.
Oh, go ahead.
Go ahead, Alice.
My apologies.
- I was just going to add,
it's a such great suggestion.
We see the sleep cast being
used a lot by young people.
And I think if,
obviously the app is free for teachers.
If any of your students
want to access the content,
there's a lot of free content on YouTube,
as well as on the website which we've
made available to everyone this year,
especially since COVID hit.
So there's plenty of free
resources there as well
even if they don't have
access to the full app.
So I would encouraged them to go
to those other channels too.
- [Jeremy] That's awesome.
So the next couple of questions are about
some of the resistance
that educators have gotten
trying to bring mindfulness
into the classroom in the past.
Mary and others have referred
to the parental resistance,
which sometimes is based in a
religious sort of objection of,
hey, doesn't this sort of go against
my own spiritual beliefs?
Is there a conflict there.
Have you heard any kind
of complaints about that
from parents that you've worked with,
and how can an educator
do that delicate dance?
- Such a great question.
Yes actually, when I
first started teaching it,
I was just in schools.
I was working for nonprofits
and I was in schools,
and I would just do it on the fly.
I would say, okay,
I see that these kids need
emotional regulation skills,
so I'm just going to do it.
And one time I had a
parent withdraw her child
from my group because
of what you just said,
these religious reasons.
She was worried that it was
conflicting with her religion,
and it brought up a lot of fear for her.
At the time I didn't
really know what to do.
I was in my early twenties
and I was very surprised
that it was being viewed that way.
But over time,
I started to realize how it can
be viewed in a threatening way.
Like, this is conflicting
with my religious practice.
And a lot of religious practices
have their own contemplative format,
right, through prayer or in other ways.
So what I would do now, I mean,
if you can talk to parents,
invite them to participate
in in the practice,
and kind of see it as a new
experience with curiosity.
Let them know that it's not a religion,
that there's a lot of,
and you might even provide
them with the scientific
research that you can find really easily.
I mean, it's all over the internet.
But bringing it back
to the brain, you know,
bringing it back to the neuroscience,
and how this is helping
their child with attention,
and focus, and how secular it is.
And that it, actually,
I've told some people
I've worked with who are,
you know, devoutly Christian
or devoutly Jewish,
that these practices can actually enhance
your connection to your religion.
They can actually help
you go deeper into prayer,
or connect with readings or teachings
that you find so deeply
meaningful in your life.
So those are just some
suggestions of bridging that gap.
You know, bringing in the science,
inviting them to practice
with you and with their child,
and encouraging them to use it as a tool.
And also reminding them
that it's part of our,
it's a natural capacity we all have.
We're just strengthening
that capacity with practice.
- [Jeremy] I love that, well said.
And I think the sort of flip side
to that question is from
the student perspective.
I remember when I was a teacher,
I would get lots of questions like, Mr. S,
why do we have to learn this?
Why does this matter?
I can certainly imagine students asking
those questions about mindfulness.
Maybe if they're younger
and they don't quite
understand the neuroscience implications,
what could you tell a student to get them
really excited about this practice?
- Yeah, so it depends on their age.
With kids who are younger,
they just want to play.
So you can do more movement.
There's a lot of like, you know,
drumming or playing a song,
like freeze dance.
A lot of classic games
that we were taught as kids
work really well as a
mindfulness teaching tool,
like red light green light.
Or what's the other one, I
have Simon says I use a lot.
And then we play Simon says,
and then we talk about attention.
And then I usually use the bell.
So I'm not even really talking
about the benefits with the kids,
with little, little ones.
I'm just kind of inviting them to play.
And while we're playing,
I'm talking a little bit about attention,
and about dealing with hard feelings.
With older kids,
sometimes I'll read a list
with their eyes closed.
I'll have, I'll read a list of emotions,
like anger, fear,
embarrassment, judgment,
and I'll ask them to just notice
what happens as they hear those feelings.
And some are positive, some
are difficult feelings.
And then when they open their eyes,
I'll ask them what they noticed.
How many of you had all those feelings
at some point in your life?
Or how many of you, like,
what feeling really stuck out to you
when I was reading that list?
And this is a jumping off
point to have a conversation
about how mindfulness
helps us deal with these
incredibly big emotions that
are arising in adolescents.
I sometimes even tell teens that, like,
a little bit about what's going on
in their brain at that age,
where their dopamine,
their brain is is a lot more susceptible
to the effects of dopamine.
So their highs are higher,
their lows are lower than adults over 26.
And just knowing,
empowering them with that
knowledge I find so important.
You know, as teens,
we had health class.
Mine was not great. (laughs quickly)
I don't think I remember or
really retained anything,
but we feel this responsibility
as teachers and adults
to educate students about their brain,
about their body.
But I think the brain,
regarding when it pertains
to emotional regulation,
largely gets neglected.
So I would say empower
them with that knowledge
and also come back to the emotion,
and come back to the, um,
a lot of students can
relate to the difficulty
in handling difficult emotions.
And they'll find a purpose and
a connection to the practice
as it helps them in that regard.
- [Jeremy] Awesome.
I know that ratatouille is
getting very crisp in the oven,
so let me finish up with one
final, very 2020 question.
Which of course is Kimberly asking,
any tips for implementing
all of this effectively,
especially in a remote or
online learning environment.
I can imagine how challenging
this might feel even in person,
but with this extra barrier
between myself and my students,
how do I cross that divide
and really make this land?
- That's a great question.
So actually, that was on one of our
slides that we didn't get to,
but it's important to have a
ritual so that kids expect,
okay, Fridays,
we're going to do a minute of mindfulness,
or mindful Mondays,
so that you have something realistic.
And you don't want to kind
of overwhelm yourself with
every day we're going to do a practice,
and then you're stressing out to find
new and interesting material every day.
So I would say start out small,
so that it's realistic for you.
Have a little plan in place,
so that you know what you're doing
and what your plan is for the week.
And then you can use resources.
Again, on the app we have,
or even on YouTube, you
can just type in Headspace,
and then you'll get these great videos.
You can go through the videos
and choose ones that you like,
that resonate with you.
And then use it as, like,
maybe carve out 10 minutes
in your class time online,
watch the video together,
and then have your
students be able to share
what came up for them while
they watched the video.
What resonated with them.
So then it's already pre-prepared for you,
that lesson and that theme,
and you don't feel like you have to create
more material and more
stress on you for that,
because that's, I think all of us,
just none of us need that right now.
We want it to be fun.
We want it to be a relief for us too.
That when we show that video
or when we offer a practice,
that it's something we need as well.
It bridges this gap between
adults and children,
adults, or teacher and student.
And it helps bring us together
as we realize we all need this pause.
We all need this ritual in our week.
- [Jeremy] Wow, I love that.
I think I'll actually give
Danielle the last word here.
She says, thank you so much for your time,
and creating this lovely space.
I can't wait to use
'stop' with my students.
And I saw so many other comments
like that throughout the session.
So I know there's going to be a lot
of more mindful classrooms and students,
and educators, starting tomorrow morning.
So on behalf of the entire Khan community,
I want to thank the full Headspace team.
Sam, Alice,
Leno has been running the
slides behind the scenes,
for making this possible.
Thank you for the swag bags
which we'll announce after this.
And thank you for Headspace for Educators,
which as you mentioned is free
at headspace.com/educators.
One last little request of
all the audience members
before we go back to our ratatouille,
is you will get a three question survey
that pops up right after the session.
Please let us know what you
thought, what was useful.
And if you'd like to have Headspace
come back and do other sessions,
let us know as well,
because we can always use
that for future programming.
That being said,
a huge thank you to everyone for investing
your scarce time with us tonight.
Hope it was well worth your while.
And thank you, Sam,
Alice, and Leno,
for sharing your expertise and your wisdom
across the country.
Thank you all so much.
- Thank you, Jeremy.
- [Jeremy] Night all.